ja wir brauchen in deutschland unbedingt
das wegrollen umgang miteinander das
miteinander trotz inhaltlicher
unterschiede ist leider zu kurz gekommen
haben verlernt über sach punkte zu
streiten ohne beleidigung zu wirken
gerade corona zeit die sich ja fronten
verhärten zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften mit dinge missbraucht werden
statt dessen tochter mit einlagen das so
wichtig ist eine krise zu bewältigen
miteinander zu reden die beste lösung zu
finden muss unser motto sein und deshalb
hat auch die ampel jetzt beschlossen
dass die digitale gewalt stärker im
fokus gerückt wird denn häufig sind auch
die netze in denen übergriff lichkeiten
stattfinden und unser anspruch muss es
sein und die am platz eingeleitet dass
wir trotz unterschiedlicher inhaltlicher
positionierungen in der sache
respektvoll miteinander umgehen ohne
beleihen zu werden ja also ich finde
dass ich gleich mal gleich ein finde das
ein super spannendes thema weil ich
komme aus dem social media bereich und
da hat man das ja tagtäglich dass die
leute diskutieren ob man jetzt hat
irgendwie gemobbt wird oder ob man seine
meinung sagen darf oder auch nicht und
finde es ganz ganz wichtig dass man das
aus verschiedenen perspektiven
betrachtet und weil das thema mobbing
beziehungsweise der gegenseite
gegenseitige respekt ist einfach sehr
sehr wichtig und finde ich dass man in
der gesellschaft viel öfter und häufiger
wieder erleben sollte ja also der umgang
ist extrem wichtig ich habe eben den
begriff zum ersten mal gehört ich finde
den sehr spannend vielleicht liegt an
mir dass ich den erst jetzt wird
digitale gewalt finde ich hervorragend
um das zu bezeichnen worum es in der
diskussion der öffentlichen wirklich
geht habt ihr neu geprägt in der
koalitionsvereinbarung
die gitarre gewalt und haben sie das
eben davon
in der letzten legislatur einen
umfassenden antrag zum rezept wie ein
tolle geholzt bekämpfung digitale gewalt
wird häufiger die übergriff lichkeiten
sind die im netz stattfinden twitter
beispielsweise sehr ist resümiert dafür
aber auch viele andere soziale netzwerke
und plattformen bieten dort die
möglichkeiten und häufig trifft es
natürlich aber auch frauen junge frauen
ganz besonders junge politiker ganz
besonders und ich wünsche mir ein land
in dem tatsächlich auf mehr junge
menschen in die politik den schönen
augen der klarname schuldige kommen die
klarnamen pflicht im internet weil das
ist das ist ja das hauptproblem 99,9
prozent gefüllt würden ja den ganzen
scheiß gar nicht schreiben und leute
machen wenn sie das mit klarer machen
müssten wäre das nicht einfach die
logische konsequenz man muss mit klarna
auf der straße trauen sich die leute ja
auch nicht die leute anzuspucken an zu
schreien an zu schubsen wobei auch das
zunehmend der fall
ist mittlerweile der fall ist aber gibt
es keiner da wurde erzählt tatsächlich
auch gefällt aber leiter karl ist das
möglich die schwelle dass der übergriff
lichkeit wird deutlich gesenkt weil man
sich ja deutlich auch als person dazu
auf muss dass man so solches verhalten
zeigt und das tatsächlich sind häufig
accounts die arme solche brutalen
beschimpfungen von sich geben die
tatsächlich keine expliziten person
absolut geäußert und die keine freunde
haben und auch keine bilder hochladen
und das ist natürlich schon bedenklich
denn noch ist es ein stück weit auch
dass man abwägen muss datenschutz
persönlichkeit thematik wie man das
aneinander er in eine andere rechtliche
grundlage wie zum beispiel boris palmer
wir werden morgen übrigens genau auch
darüber bei bild berichten über hass im
netz und wo es keine grünen politiker
oberbürgermeister von tübingen den habe
ich heute um statement gebeten und er
hat mir dann geschrieben dass er schon
über 100 fälle angezeigt hat
strafrechtlich also eher digital weit
über 100 mal angezeigt strafrechtlich
nicht ein einziges mal wurde ein
verfahren eröffnet und er hat gesagt die
gesetzliche grundlage muss dringend
nachgeschärft werden was wird die fdp da
machen genau das ist ja teil auch des
koalitionsvertrages denn wir verankert
haben die lückenlose umsetzung der
istanbul konvention und die istanbul
konvention wo ist er in einem jahr
entstanden wo das thema digital netz sie
ja noch gar nicht vorhanden war und
deshalb ist es notwendig neben vereine
und schloss dormagen die istanbul
konvention in eigenregie den kampf gegen
häusliche gewalt gegenüber frauen männer
aber auch kinder und jugendliche was
lustiges dass es in istanbul gerade
passiert war vorbildlich das alles
machen
einige länder die auch aus dem start
nicht ausgesehen jetzt können wir
zweiter
da unbedingt digitale gewalt mit dazu
und das muss man erst mal die weichen
stellen es gibt auch dass die justiz die
die polizei die rechtsprechung auch
entsprechend geschult werden muss welche
möglichkeiten existieren denn auch ein
stückweit sensibilisiert werden muss
denn es ist ein wahrlich ein problem und
gerade junge menschen die im sozialen
netz tätig sie wolle gott sagen also ja
ich glaube und jetzt angesprochen hast
sollten wir die namen wirklich dann
hinter den accounts legen ich denke
jeder account hinter dem account steckt
eine person also ein mensch ja heißt es
ganz wichtig dass gerade auch creator
influenza wie auch immer man sie nennen
möchte einfach als vorbild fungieren und
dafür viel mehr ansetzen und sie sich
zum beispiel auch nicht untereinander
mobbten oder wie auch immer sondern
einfach zeigen dass man dass diese
umgänge auch im netz leben kann ja es
geht nicht darum immer besser und anders
als ich schon auch die medien anfang an
zum beispiel frau bauer sie waren gerade
erst betroffen finde ich bei tv total
ich fand es eigentlich genau
wieso sehen wir selbst soll ich gerade
aktuell ein bisschen auch übers ziel
hinaus geschossen aber
auch dass man sich dann in die nette
leute hier besorgen nach ausgeschlossen
die frage ist die frage ist ja ganz klar
jetzt die wunden bei tv total da hat man
ja die sexieste biene der fdp gesucht
das waren absolut unding für mich aber
muss man da nicht haben sie sich da zum
beispiel beschwerden direkt gesagt also
hier fehlt mir der respekt ihm gegenüber
als politikerin sollte man da nicht auch
schon einsetzen vielleicht ja was ich da
spannend gefunden habe dass nicht nur
ich mich beschwert haben es ist immer
schwierig wenn man als betroffener sich
beschwert sondern dass sich eine
unglaubliche solidarität im netz
gebildet hat unterschiedlicher menschen
hans chr akten so geht es nicht wissen
im 21 jahrhundert uns noch mein
statement wir sind im 21 jahrhundert
eine frau die politik machen möchte die
unser land gestalten möchte wird darauf
reduziert dass sie gut aussieht ist dass
die eigenschaft die wir thematisieren
wollen passiert es denn den männern auch
oder wollen wir ein land in den respekt
zollt in dem wir wirklich veränderungen
auf den weg bringen wollen indem wir
auch hart streiten das sache aber
trotzdem immer respektvoll miteinander
um ich wünsche ich mir und es hat mir
die ampel gezeigt allein die ganzen
koalitionsverhandlungen auch das
sondierungs papier wie wenig da nach
außen gedrungen ist aber wie eben
zusammengearbeitet hat und ich kann
sagen ich war selber in der
arbeitsgruppe klima energie und
transformationen natürlich würde hart
gerungen über die themen ist noch keine
leichten themen gerade auch wenn man
sagt was für erwartungen oder was das
auch für möglicherweise für für die
bürgerinnen und bürger bedeutet aber
hart zu streiten und deshalb dort
dennoch respektvoll miteinander
umzugehen finde ich schon notwendig und
mir war es unglaublich wichtig das ist
da eine welle ausgehe wirklich
losgetreten habe dass viele menschen
sich die fragestellung so geht's nicht
ich kriege immer noch zuschriften aber
ich habe eben auch in dieser zeit
zuschriften erhalten die mehr als unter
der gürtellinie waren wo ich schon sagen
muss wo auch diejenigen die mal auch
stück weit mit denen nicht um ein social
media kanal gezeigt habe auch ein
bisschen mit lesen konnten wo ich schon
sagt das muss sich verändern